I've I found more that get what girls
will do is the guy will be Broad and say
oh I'm looking you know he might not say
specifically what he's looking for but
if you say are you looking for a
relationship specifically like they they
usually tell you the truth yeah yeah yes
or no like no they might say no I'm not
doubting they do if I can't I think
there's a good 20 of people that lie no
the right guys the right guys the
scumbag no I don't want to say something
about a guy that doesn't get a lot of
girls I don't think it's just that dog
or a guy that's not confident in himself
we'll tell you what you want to hear but
a guy that knows what he wants I'll tell
you exactly nah so do you know what it
is I feel like guys because it's so easy
a guy that knows what he wants will just
tell you
like the kind of guy if I wasn't with my
girl knows this as well I don't beat
around the bush if I'm trying to [ __ ] a
girl I'll just let you know straight up
listen I'm trying to hit what are you
saying and if it's not that and to get
that it's not just a random girl either
it's a girl that I would have interacted
with before obviously you don't just go
into random guys I'm trying to hit what
you're saying but you'll get here this
is what I'm saying more time you have to
just be open and just I don't want to
waste no much time I want to waste no
one's time I wouldn't want someone
wasting my time either so if that's the
direction I'm trying to go with that
girl I'll let it know I'll let you know
from the start I'm not trying to waste
my time or your time now where are we
going with this that's a good thing but
vice versa if I'm looking for a
relationship would be the same thing as
well I'll let you know from a jump not
everyone is like this yeah
okay I'm curious guy's point of view do
you feel like most girls when they pick
a toxic guy they know from the jump he's
trouble yeah like like maybe maybe he
might lie but like they can't girls can
smell other girls around him yeah I
won't say necessarily other girls yeah
but it's like it's like I feel like you
know I feel like let's be real yeah like
people know to an extent you should know
when you're being lied to it depends for
example like like I can say I love you
this guy don't take you on dates you
don't give you flowers you don't do this
you should kind of know you're not ready
like you can say whatever words you want
yeah I'm but let's be real he's not
showing it yeah so it's like so I feel
like I get that you know what because
I've got man them yet and I speak to
them and I'm like
me personally I've never me I've only
been into relationships so yeah I don't
do relationships unless I've really want
to dedicate my time and stuff but I've
asked my guys and I said like why do you
lie to I'm seeing you chat to this girl
you're misleading a wider and he's like
bro she wants to hear this yeah so
sometimes it's like I'll be sometimes
you want to hear these lies because it's
like girls will say that sometimes I
don't want to sleep with someone unless
I'm in a relationship so you don't feel
like a a foot or whatever word but then
it's like this is a fake relationship
this is just for your peace of mind so
you want to hear these lies so you can
tell yourself I was in a relationship I
don't know it too I think I think
sometimes girls say that though just for
the sake of saying it like you're saying
we want to hear certain things and
obviously if your behavior doesn't
reflect that as in like you were saying
you know you're not taken out you're not
shown off you haven't met any friends or
anything like that like we do the same
thing
well some women do I'm one of those
women but to be honest from the get-go
is the best thing no definitely yeah it
does everyone does need a little ego
boost and also we all do want to be
Charmed a little bit like you said if
you just walked up to someone and said
I'm just trying to hit that yeah it's it
might work but very rare yeah it's a
certain kind of guy that can get away
with that yeah you have to have a
certain you know what I mean it's not
everyone yeah so I think people might
not like it but I think they'll respect
it yeah for the honesty oh yeah of
course it's honest I I feel like honesty
is the best policy I'm just saying I
feel like obviously people lie because
sometimes people want to hit like I said
some people generally want exactly is so
much let's be real it is easier to lie
at times but then it's like if you're a
good person that's why you don't like
you know what I mean because you like
you feel morally wrong but is it easier
to lie yes it definitely is that's why
some people just like yo she knows I
don't like her
but let me light up I'm confused you to
tell the truth I've got a question
definitely though for you you know the
guy that sorry you know the guy that um
you're in a situation with did he lie to
you about where you're at
yeah
yeah and when at what point did you
figure out it was a lie
probably you don't have to you don't
have to answer if you don't want no I'm
gonna be very honest because I do feel
like
we all have to take accountability for
our own actions do you see what I mean
yeah
um
quite early on probably six months in
okay and how long has it been two years
all right
and you still like Maddie and love or
not madly I don't know like you still
got feelings for him
yeah that's honest I appreciate that
yeah what makes you stay you just feel
like you can't walk away
[Music]
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
I think I did think that
I definitely think I was maybe living in
a bit of Hope
maybe there's like a bit of a carrot
being dangled in front of me you know
when I was realizing or when I was
questioning certain things
um
I think I'm probably in a better place
now because I'm quite aware of what the
situation is and I'm quite ready to just
kind of you know like move forward which
is great
um
I can't knock him completely because I
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words
um and I think some women will
ignore that because it's not what they
want to see it's not what they want to
feel you know they want to believe like
nah this guy's right for them but in
reality if someone is showing you
something yeah you've really got to take
that in so
um how old did you say you are 33 33. do
you ever worry like do you want a family
and like kids and stuff I've got a son
okay who's 14. okay
um I would want to have another child
however I do feel like I'm on a
short time frame now yeah well because I
would just think
um because I I've like broken up with
people or like ended things because I
don't want to waste time and because you
only have so much youth you know do you
ever worry you can't find someone else
because you're still emotionally
invested with this guy absolutely yeah I
feel like I've probably done that for
quite a while yeah so I definitely think
about them I call it blocking my
blessings yeah you know if you're
emotionally invested in someone else
then you might miss someone amazing
because you're mentally still there do
you know what I mean
um
yeah I think it's just I think women
generally speaking of it there's a lot
of us that do need to really take in
what's put in front of us so and this is
a common like complaint I hear from guys
because like they value you know Purity
and they value youth right and so like a
common complaint is okay you passed over
me in your 20s in your early 30s and now
you're expecting me to come in at 35 and
deal with all the damage that the
previous guys have done for the past
decade and it's it's funny because
everyone's like nodding they're like
yeah that happens yeah
so do you feel like that's for men an
unfair deal yes yeah I do wow that's
bigger you to say it's not fair because
I don't believe they should have to deal
with anyone's past trauma yeah that's
been caused by someone else I think it's
amazing if you do meet a man that wants
to be understanding to that level where
they want to try and fix that or help
you to heal but I definitely don't think
it's fair that women
put their past trauma on someone new
that they meet someone that comes into
their life that hasn't done nothing to
them they might that man might be
amazing it might be great you know but
because we've experienced
bad experiences and we've got that
trauma and that bit of scarring
we project that onto them that's because
you haven't healed yeah because
obviously you haven't taken that self
that time for yourself to focus and heal
and deal with over whatever your
problems were or your insecurities and
then you just hand it on to the next
person and obviously nobody's going to
handle that well so so what is healing
to you because I always hear this and I
don't I don't think you can like you
they say the average person falls in
love three times in their lifetime yeah
so you only get so many chances at love
and it's like I don't think anyone fully
heals no I think when I when I refer to
the term as healing I'm I'm like take
yourself back look at the situation look
at the mistakes you may have made
yourself look at the things you allowed
to happen that might have hurt you
um and and vice versa what the things
that you may have done to that partner
in order for them to behave in a certain
way that you then felt again was
targeted so I think when I say healing
I'm take yourself back take some time
out you know just focus on your health
focus on your mental well-being and do
whatever it takes whether it's
meditation whether it's a holiday
whether it's reading books like learning
a new skill that to me is healing so
when I've healed myself in the past I
haven't gone to a therapist on a
telephone that I don't know and I'm not
saying that that's not the right thing
to do although that it's the wrong thing
to do but for me I just took time out I
stopped dating I separated anyone from
my life that maybe I felt was putting me
in a predicament or making me behave or
act a certain way and just focused on me
and then eventually you come back to
yourself and so um a common complaint
that I hear from guys and it's funny
because as a girl like I know exactly
what you're saying but a lot of times
when guys hear this that sounds like
nonsense yeah and it's because there's
no tangible result yeah like there's
nothing that you can measure and say
that you did it's just like okay you
went on a vacation I don't know and you
thought about what you did wrong and
you're gonna do it better like how do
they know you're going to do it better
in the future yeah yeah when I see I'm
thinking out yeah right now what what
have you achieved after that yeah like
when I say a vacation I'm talking six
months somewhere I'm not talking a
holiday to Ibiza for seven days with the
girls and hey I'm over you yeah like I'm
talking like somewhere where you really
really take yourself out of your current
lifestyle your daily routine and then
you can evaluate and obviously there is
no time on healing healing probably
takes years never get over everything
but healing to a point then you don't
transfer it onto the next relationship
but I don't think you can not transfer
things to another you can't no you if
you take enough time I feel like you can
you can but there's always going to be
things that may trigger you and it's up
to you I don't I I genuinely think that
there's some things that your partner
might do that will prompt a random
response yeah like you didn't even know
that you had as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible